bonjour messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors françois
et ramon three quatre manifestations
aujourd'hui
rien qu'à paris comprenez vous à ce
mouvement de protestation oui enfin je
vois bien d'ailleurs dans les dents les
interventions que vous avez filmé qu'il
ya il ya plusieurs choses
il ya différents des différents niveaux
il ya ceux qui parlent une croyance ne
crois pas aux vaccins ce qu'on peut
parler de croyance à ce stade puisque
scientifiquement je pense que non on est
quand même largement assez éprouvée sur
la sueur losc a parlé les vaccins et
notamment la sni pour le coc vide et
puis à ceux qui sont tous dans une forme
de e 2 crainte c'est pas que je n'y
crois pas mais qui ont une 102
d'appréhension sur le vaccin et qui est
tout à fait compréhensible et en fait le
pass sanitaire finalement vient les met
dans une position un petit peu
d'enfermement c'est à dire d'un côté ils
ont la crainte du vaccin
donc ils vont pas souhaité se faire
vacciner et d'un autre côté on a un
loiret leçons et se sentent contraints
puisqu'ils se disent donc peu plus
normalement parce qu'elle passe à
lithaire donc obligation d'un vaccin qui
nous fait un petit peu peur c'est ça qui
crée et ses contraintes
cette volonté de se défendre comme toi
tout être vivant à être des êtres
humains quand on se sent un peu aculé de
hauts murs on a envie de 2 de ceux de se
battre en tout cas de faire valoir ses
revendications mais ce qu'il faut bien
retenir c'est qu'on est dans une
situation qui est même très particulière
en temps normal c'est ces sujets là sont
très largement débattue et pendant très
longtemps les cas des vaccins c'est pas
nouveau on s'insurge été débattue depuis
des des années des années mais là on est
dans une situation de crise où on a un
possible regain de là
des mini avec le variant delta on voit
les chiffres qui sont en train de la
d'exploser à nouveau donc
donc là il faut que les décisions soient
prises vite très vite pour limiter des
pertes humaines un des b c et d
hospitalisation en réanimation et des
choses très graves
donc il faut un débat qui soit rapide
une prise de décision qui aiment
nécessairement rapide mais petit pour
autant aucune finalité qui est tout à
fait meubles et et qu'il faut garder en
tête qui est de sauver des vies et
d'empêcher des maladies graves et l'ont
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui cette
situation est la meilleure possible si
on avait atteint facilement 80 % de taux
de vaccination il y aurait pas besoin de
passer ni terre quelque part est
probablement qu'on verrait des chiffres
qui ne sont pas autant en russe donc là
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore à 50% de
taux de vaccinés totalement en france
avec un peu plus de 47% il me semble
donc il faut des moyens d'accélérer le
mouvement et des moyens de contrôler
aussi l'épidémie tout en maintenant une
certaine activité économique et je pense
que le pass nder aujourd'hui au vu de la
situation est une bonne solution mais je
comprends tout à fait les manifestations
du fait de cette situation qui semble
contradictoire pour certaines personnes
carbon ne cesse vous êtes avocat la
prochaine étape pour le passage du ter
sont le conseil constitutionnel que
peut-on attendre le conseil
constitutionnel lui même si je rejoins
l'essentiel de ce qui vient des tripes
départ du docteur kaminski mu ne peut
pas être au stade p dans l'urgence
donc ce qu'on peut en attendre c'est
précisément en matière de libertés
publiques c'est à dire que les juristes
ne sont pas des virologues et ne se
prennent pas ça mais par contre
rappellent que les valeurs fondamentales
d'une civilisation ne valent pas que
pour les temps de calme mais également
en tant de crise y compris la crise
sanitaire
oki urgence un plaid par un variant de
du cornât virus est une évidence par
contre que l'exécutif
hothead au mépris de la méthode
démocratique
je vais y revenir et des règles
fondamentales qui sont imposés par la
convention d'oviedo par la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et par
la constitution
voilà ce à quoi va payer le procès est
constitutionnelle avec sans doute une
faculté pour lui de rappeler alex les
cultive une notion fondamentale de
l'actualisation française depuis les
lumières c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs
or à quoi assistons-nous précisément au
nom de l'un des deux l'urgence argué par
le docteur crasneanscki et au genre ce
qu'on ne remet pas en cause mais on
avait le temps d'anticiper ce bail en
tête
vous verrez que la vie et d'état qui a
été rendue rappel qui n'est pas normal
de le saisir en urgence sur une question
aussi fondamentale
il précise même que il ne garantit pas
la validité juridique de son propre avis
au regard de l'urgence à laquelle il est
un et le sénat vient de se plaindre de
ce qu'il a été contraint de statuer en
urgence
c'est à dire que vous allez veiller à la
fois le pouvoir judiciaire et le pouvoir
législatif qui envoie un signal très
clair aux pouvoirs exécutifs en lui
disant que même au nom de l'urgence on
doit continuer à fonctionner en
respectant les mots d'un mental et les
libertés et les libertés individuelles
et en même temps le rappelle que le mode
de fonctionnement des institutions n'est
pas celui de la mapi choper marche
forcée qu'il ya un pardon des choses sur
prenons par exemple d'avoir un système
d'information de la diffusion du virus
qui s'appelle le daip qui est le protégé
par le secret médical n'est accessible
que pour laborantins pharmacien c'est à
dire autant de professions qui sont
soumises au secret médical
il était prévu dans l'article 4 projet
de loi que les services de police pubis
y avoir accès pour aller contrôler si
les gens se confient les biens une fois
déclarée positive
il a fallu que ce soit le sénat qui
s'empare de la question l'assemblée
l'avait validée à ce que peut-être
avait-il pas vu le problème que ça
posait en matière de libertés publiques
et le gouvernement avait oublié de
vendenheim ou de la cnib parce qu'il
savait très bien que la cnil allait
émettre un avis défavorable sur cette
violation halles et du et des données
personnelles que vous menez un fils et a
facilité le combat du virus par les
médecins dont voulait s'emparer les
services de police pas forcément avec
une visée liberticide
voyez où ne taxe pas le gouvernement
d'attention liberticide
on n'est pas dans une dictature
simplement il ya quand même
même avant la dictature méthode carbone
je suis désolé on est on est pressé par
le temps s'il veut avoir le temps de
vous donner la parole à tous les deux on
va être un peu plus court françois
krakowski vous le disions il ya deux
débats il ya ceux qui a reçu deux passes
auditeurs par rapport à la privation des
libertés et puis ceux qui s'interrogent
sur l'utilité du vaccin
l'efficacité du vaccin justement est ce
que les autorités
le gouvernement a à ces communautés
autour
j'ai l'impression qu'on est quand même
depuis depuis le début de la campagne de
vaccination
une information qui est riche et dense
inventé en de deux campagnes sanitaires
auger malgré ma faiblesse et et j'ai pas
souvenir d'avoir vu des campagnes aussi
importante sur sur les sujets de
vaccination et puis un sujet aussi voilà
sanitaire qui au premier plan depuis
maintenant deux ans alors que la santé
c'est pas toujours un sujet d'actualité
prégnant donc je pense qu'il ya vraiment
une information qui est qui est forte
maintenant l'information qui doit être
faite à des personnes qui sont plus dans
doute soit qu'ils ont ou qui ont des
craintes et qui sont quelque part les
législatives le droit de craindre
certaines choses il faut les accompagner
mais
ces accompagnements pour expliquer le
fond de la question qu est ce qu on sait
qu est ce qu on sait pas souvent ces
craintes ont lié à un sentiment qu'on
peut cacher des choses qui est pas
forcément cas c'est simplement qu'il
faut prendre le temps d'expliquer des
choses qui sont assez techniques sur
plan médical un scientifique et et du
coup ces personnes mais il faut prendre
le temps de les accompagner
sauf que là c'est ce que l'on explique
c'est qu'il fut malheureusement enfin
pour retrouver une situation normale vie
normale et pour éviter au maximum des
dégâts médicaux et sanitaires d'un mois
des décès rappelle toujours il faut il
faut il faut aller vite donc finalement
poussé un petit peu mais on rappelle
tout de même que c'est pour le bien
collectif et et puis pour retrouver une
vie normale
c'est quand même très intéressant de
voir qu'on avait une courbe de
vaccination qui s'aplatit c'est un peu
en dessous des 45 % et que depuis
l'annnonce du président que du passé ni
terre il ya un engouement nouveau pour
la vaccination voilà ce qui me très bien
que finalement on a à pompe peut-être
une petite moitié de la population qui
est on veut dire qu'il ya une culture
sanitaire anses poitiers voilà qui est
convaincu 2 du fait scientifique de la
vaccination et puis avec une volonté
quand même solidaires devoir sortir le
pays et tous ensemble de la crise et
puis qu'on a une frange de la population
qui finalement attendait une bonne
raison peut-être plus personnel mais sa
libre à chacun d'aller se faire vacciner
le passé à lutter en armes a été
finalement bon quand on parle de
liberticide part je pense que cette se
passent-elles terre c'est un entre deux
à l'obligation vaccinale
après sur le plan purement juridique in
some prononcer mais d'un point de vue
sanitaire
disons qu'il ya une frondeuse part
d'autonomie qui nécessite une
responsabilisation si on dit que par
chacun fait ce qu'il veut
d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'il prend
la responsabilité à la fois 2-2 d'élèves
malades et les possiblement de prendre
en charge ses soins et si la
responsabilité de contamination d'autres
si on part du principe que c'est le
gouvernement la france l'état qui est
responsable de ça
population dans ce cas il faut jouer le
jeu françois comme en ski merci car bond
de 16 le pass sanitaires on le sait
c'est un outil pour minimiser les
risques de contamination du virus et
notamment du variant et donc pousser à
la vaccination ça veut dire quoi que le
gouvernement les autorités ont échoué
quant à leur stratégie de communication
écoutez moi je suis pas spécialiste de
la communication mais ce que je peux
constater d'abord dire que le fait
d'être vaccinées dont cache pas d'être
contagieux intentions il faut pas
raconter n'importe quoi à vos
téléspectateurs
de même que l'on voit on a perdu le
leader kassav qui était vacciné
si vous voulez le vaccin immunise
malheureusement pas de tout ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'ils nous conduit vers un
monde e meilleur point de vue sanitaire
maintenant sur la communication
précisément qui a commencé par tourner
en ridicule les gens qui émettait des
doutes sur les vaccins certains de façon
irrationnelle d'autres deux factions
parfaitement rationnel la façon qu'elle
gouvernement aussi d'infantiliser les
français précisément envoyer leurs gains
vient de dire le médecin le regain de
vaccination à la suite des annonces
effectuées par le président de la
république au bien qu'on a fonctionné
quand même sur la peur donc on peut pas
dire que on est en train de valoriser la
citoyenneté et les spécifique des
français c'est la peur de vivre de façon
confortable la peur d'avoir accès à son
travail au droit aux loisirs aux trois à
la culture
ce sont ces craintes cumulé qui ont
coûté un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes à se faire vacciner il
s'agit pas de les juger mais il s'agit
de juger précisément la communication du
gouvernement qui a pas réussi à
convaincre du bénéfice d'une vaccination
massive et qui a eu recours à aa
defacto le fait de diminuer la nation
française
cette plénitude de leurs droits ont
vacciné qu'ils ne peuvent pas jouir de
la plénitude de leurs droits à ce qu'il
nomme pas l'intégralité de leurs
vaccinations et ça ça pose
vos le problème et de la communication
et du respect de l'égalité des citoyens
français
carbon de 16 vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris merci à bon d'avoir répondu à
nos questions françois krakowski vous
vous êtes médecin spécialiste de santé
publique merci à vous également
messieurs d'avoir été sur rt france en
direct